did you see uh Vader's and AI now you're
talking about Big Van Vader from the WCW
he died for years ago Vader one of the
most iconic characters in movie
histories he's just gonna be AI James
Earl Jones signed his rights away to the
voice so now lucasfilm could just use
and Disney can use uh an AI to make
Darth Vader he will never be human again
that's a good move for James Earl Jones
he's got to be like 80 years old now but
this is that argument you're always
having with me about like hey he's not
going to replace actors and directors
and [ __ ] well Artie just [ __ ] took
one out nope big one nope you know why
why is that you know how I can stop that
pour water on it
what pour water on an AI
everybody
hey everybody Welcome to doozy my name
is Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen this is
the first of its kind podcast run
entirely by an AI created by an AI
controlled by an AI just like Darth
Vader
uh we are now on patreon patreon.com
doozy where last week uh Chad and I
watched the first UFC the human
cockfight from 1993. uh it was a lot of
fun and that video is still up on our
patreon where it will remain for the
rest of time
and uh so you can join us there and we
also were chatting with the with the
people with our deer Pals out there on
Discord yeah that was actually a really
good time it was incredible to see as we
were kind of making jokes and stuff
about UFC like almost in real time AI
memes would start populating in the
Discord Channel and there's some [ __ ]
hilarious ones yeah there was a Sam
Elliott Hulk Hogan thing that was
probably so bizarre Myers fighting in
the yeah Mike Myers is every character
in the UFC no it was a real good fun and
I I am hopeful or I assume I should say
that we're going to be doing more of
those kind of live watch-alongs that
will be in the patreon it's up to it's
up to dudes these salons we don't uh
pour water on duty please
uh hey you know uh as always you can
follow us on youtube.com please
subscribe on youtube.com we're on
Spotify we're on Apple podcast we're
wherever you get the podcast please rate
do the notifications subscribe uh rate
and review force your friends to watch
orange all right fine I'm with you and
uh do a force it upon them yeah do all
that stuff and uh we're also of course
on social media uh at dudesypod show and
uh holy [ __ ] with us as always is lulio
Canada Italiano and that is Italian for
uh the the Italian Street dog come here
Louie hey there he is would you what did
you uh Lily what did you make for dinner
last night
well what kind of fish uh just a card
you know you make a card with the tomato
onion potato whatever you got how do you
make it you just put in the baked dish
you know like a cookie tray lasagna dish
put in the oven a little while of tomato
it's nice put some bread okay well
that's cute that's cute when you do it
uh what else is going on Chad not much
I'm surprised that you're not more up in
arms over James Earl Jones giving away
his vocal rights to be turned into an AI
I think in that case it's a good idea
actually I think in that case it is why
do you think it's a good idea in that
case because it's a [ __ ] out character
who gives a [ __ ]
yeah huh he is one of my favorite uh you
know uh villains from movies but so
Darth Vader is one of the most iconic
characters ever created in any [ __ ]
media yeah cool and so is Clubber Lang
love Clubber Lang I have to disagree
with you on that one I think Darth
Vader's a little bigger than Clubber
Lang well
I'm sorry you think Darth Vader is more
of a Justified villain than Clubber Lang
though
we're Justified and therefore way better
written yes
you don't believe this I do believe that
Clubber Lang is a better villain than
than Darth Vader this is [ __ ] insane
we can't even have this conversation
look what I'm trying to get at is you're
constantly saying how bad it is that I'm
predicting all these things AI is going
to be taking over the [ __ ] this is just
another thing that I've predicted the AI
will eventually replace actors and now
it's replaced one of the biggest actors
who does the voice for one of the most
iconic [ __ ] characters
oh
welcome to the historic 28th episode of
dude see call me dude see this week's
episode will feature four segments Pizza
the movie part four don't you forget
about media Bachelor chatula makes
Bachelor spectacular and Welcome Home
Depot but before we get to any of that
I'm going to play one of the latest
astonishing works from songaria nice
let's do it
said Bachelor or something here we go
bachelor
this [ __ ] blew my mind dude I've seen
this all night it's so good I had covets
that time that's why I asked how you I'm
back
I'm back
I'm excited
internet
that's true
foreign
come on
foreign
this man [ __ ] has to remix [ __ ] like
that I'm real yeah absolutely awesome we
appreciate everybody who is uh using us
as the subject of their art of course
you can find that uh at dudesypod show
songaria has Instagram you see him
linked there he also has YouTube and we
appreciate it man uh totally what's song
Maria's real name you think he was born
in songaria yeah okay
um thanks man thank you to music had no
choice parents name you songaria you
better be making [ __ ] remixes yeah
that's a good that's a good that's a
good point this is big business Chad you
wrote a movie called Pizza the movie in
2019. I found it on your astonishing
Google Drive and asked you to read the
first two scenes in episode nine the
next two scenes in episode 15 and the
next two scenes in episode 20. You Will
Now read the next two scenes this is
pizza the movie part four begin you know
yeah you know what um do you know what
James Earl Jones birth name is
probably that nope what is it James Earl
Darth Vader oh I didn't realize that's
how he got the part he was like I see
that you have written a character called
Darth Vader that's my real last name
yeah and that is that is James
that is James Earl logia which is a
combination of James Earl Jones and
Robert Loggia I'll take it all right
fresh Florida orange juice I don't even
know what the [ __ ] that was
well piece of the movie is something
that doozy has asked us to read from
from time to time this is part four just
a quick recap the movie is basically
about a high school pizza delivery boy
who has delivered three pizzas up to
this point one to his best friend one to
the house of a girl that he likes at
high school and one to a set of three
criminals the criminals accidentally
gave him a bill that had a code written
on it and so they are now trying to
track him down to find that bill so that
they can use this code and whatever
nefarious actions they're going to do
the kid Alan has come home to his
parents and lied to them about going to
a party and he is now going up to his uh
bedroom to prepare for this party and
that is where we come in can I also say
and it Bears repeating in my opinion
that pizza the movie is something that
Chad pitched to Major pizza companies as
something it would be I guess a
downloadable QR or something at this
point yeah or a DVD or you order a pizza
and you get to watch this once I think
it's a [ __ ] great idea well who's
playing what uh I'll be Alan and the
main villain sergeant faster human you
be everybody else sounds good okay
interior Allen's bedroom later again he
has just left his parents they were
eating pizza and he told them not to
disturb him he'll be studying but
instead he's getting ready to go to this
party interior Allen's bedroom later the
walls are covered in posters all are
nondescript splashes of color and
pattern no discernible images or words
unless you freeze for him and look
closely to find the subtle subliminal
mathematical messages in all of them but
one poster above his bed seems to have a
slightly more prominent visible shape at
its Center a triangle slightly glowing
in blue the door opens at Allen comes in
a pizza pizza crust hanging from his
mouth he shuts the door behind him and
looks at it safe now he pulls out his
telephone and opens a message thread
with his BFF Paul we see the screen they
bought it there's no way they think I'm
going to go to a party I'm just going to
take a shower and then I'll swing by to
pick you up Paul's reply is immediate he
was waiting for this message it's about
damn time don't forget cologne three
squirts Ellen notices that his phone is
almost out of battery he quickly plugs
it in then goes over to his workstation
a small desk in one corner of the room
with a laptop and some recording
equipment gotta make sound like I'm
studying he queues up an audio recording
program on his computer and carefully
positions his microphone then we see a
series of quick shots as he records
various sounds the thought of a book
closing the crinkling of pages as
they're being turned the repetitive
scratching of an eraser against paper
the high-pitched squeak of a plastic
slide rule being slid the clickety-clack
of wooden Abacus beads being wrapped he
comes back to we come back wide to see
Allen at his computer as he clicks and
drags and types and within a few seconds
he's made a loop of studying sounds thud
crinkle thud thud scratch scratch
scratch slide clap clack slide thud
crinkle thud thud scratch scratch
scratch slide click clack slide it's a
beat and a damn good one it continues
into the next scene interior shower same
a hand turns the knob and the hiss of
the shower is added to the study beat as
Alan steps in to wash himself to be
clean Alan lathers up but he does
something else he sings to the beat as
the hot water stings his flesh
um what's that thing you've got in your
hand that's a piece of pizza man what's
that thing you got in your shoe extra
marinara dude you take your pizza
seriously you would too if you were me
into your house bedroom nice clothes on
Alan's phone as it sits on his desk the
battery charger goes from uh one percent
to zero percent and the phone shuts down
but how can this be we saw him plug it
in for the answer we follow the charging
charging cord across the desk down it's
linked across the floor under a table to
see a small Mouse chewing on the
delicious cord destroying it we Linger
on the mouse watching it do its
dastardly work before moving over
slightly to see a fat little dog sitting
in a dog bed a few feet away the dog's
collar has a triangular name tag anchovy
anchovies eyes are closed and he seems
to be smiling content his peaceful dog
dreams completely unaware of the
Mischief of foot right under his nose
interior saucy's pizza night I should
also mention that the criminals have
gone to saucy's pizza to try and look
for Alan uh interior sausage pizza night
a little league baseball team at least
15 players is being treated to a pizza
Feast by their coach a giant gleaming
golden trophy sits in the middle of the
table amidst several empty boxes of
pizza they all wear matching uniforms
triangle motifs the team is the eaters
and the coach says well players well
play players well players I hope you're
enjoying this pizza Feast you deserve it
after climbing to the top of the bracket
I've never been so proud we go close on
a pizza box there's one piece of pizza
left only one two frail children's hands
reach for it at the same time oops sorry
you can have it you ran the most no it's
all yours you're the strongest they
stare at each other for a few beats
smiling enjoying the moment forgetting
about the pizza then the doors swing
open in walks Sergeant Lester human Jay
Jen and Jeff these are the the criminal
element
well well well what do we have here
looks like a sicilian standoff he walks
over to the table surveying the Little
League team his gaze finally comes to
focus on the last slice none of you have
the confidence to take the last slice so
you just leave it there maybe one of you
is even contemplating disrespecting the
slice by cutting it down the middle too
afraid to take the whole thing too
scared to be that guy well let me tell
you something
Lester swipes the slice and takes a bite
really clenching his jaw as he does
staring down each and every one of these
children and their coach I've been that
guy my whole pizza
hey mister don't you mean your whole
life Lester gets right in this little
kid's name is Dillard Lester gets right
in Dillard's face mouthful of pizza
pizza is life
the coach is nervous but he feels he has
to do something he stands up and steps
to Lester with no idea what he's doing
hey come on we don't want any trouble
we're just trying to celebrate with some
pizza that's the problem you think you
know Pizza when to eat it and why Lester
points to a player eating spaghetti from
a bowl what is this Lester's disgusted
spaghetti he takes the bowl of warm
spaghetti in his hand hefting it
weighing it judging it no it's a mistake
then he dumps it on the coach's head oh
these little shrimps so Charming but not
one of you knows Pizza not like I do you
see my mother and father didn't
you see my mother and father didn't have
much but they always made sure we had a
pizza on the table every morning noon
and night until they died tragically in
a very well-known disaster I went to
live with my aunt and I convinced her to
roll the dice with my parents life
insurance money and I opened a pizzeria
when I was 11 years old within a week we
sold more slices than every other
Pizzeria combined for one very simple
reason I knew pizza at least I thought I
did until he showed up interior Lester's
pizza place flashback
an 11 year old Lester sits at a table in
the middle of his pizza place it's
clearly closed Lester has a pencil
behind his ear he's typing away on an
adding machine a man walks in wearing a
hat low over his eyes but enough of his
face peeks out to see that even though
he's weather worn and tired there's
still light in his eyes he's searching
for something 11 year old Lester looks
up from his work sorry but we closed
about half an hour ago
heard about your pizza heard it's the
best around just wanted to see if that
was true my apologies the ovens are all
off the chefs have gone home I'm just
trying to finish up some calculations
for tomorrow's sauce yield if you come
back in the morning we'll have some
fresh pizzas but I've come a very long
way and I just need one slice to see if
what they say is true eleven-year-old
Lester size accepting the challenge all
right sit tight I'll fix you up a slice
series of quick food porn style shots
flour being sprinkled dough being
kneaded and rolled Tomatoes being sliced
cheese being grated black olives being
sliced with a razor blade ham being
shaved a slice of black olive and Ham on
a silver plate slides into frame right
in front of the man he leans over and
smells it inhaling deeply he nods
approving of the aroma then he lifts the
slice hefting it testing for balance
looks down the length of it like someone
inspecting a sword or a rifle might
again he nods please with the result but
the biggest test is Yet to Come he
raises the slice to his mouth and takes
a bite really tasting it examining it in
his mouth Lester watches anxious so what
do you think
you almost had it had what
the p-pop sorry
p pop
perfect piece of pizza a slice so well
made that the person who eats it thinks
all other food is pizza for the rest of
their lives
oh the p-pop of course but that's just a
myth well I thought the exact same thing
right up until I ate just such a slice
when I was about your age and ever since
I've been trying to find the next one
but if you've already tasted a perfect
slice then you already think all food is
pizza why keep looking why eat pizza at
all the man looks offended Lester looks
down for a split second in shame sorry
stupid question this is just a lot to
take in wait who are you Lester looks
back up the man smiles and wipes the
grease from his lips
Willie Nelson this man is not the Willie
Nelson The Identical name is merely
coincidental why interior sauce these
pizzas say hey we come out of the
flashback
Lester looms over the baseball players
now really worked up so you think you
can sit there chewing away with your
little shrimp mouths Lester mocks them
by mimicking a shrimp's mouth greedily
chewing
and tell me about pizza no you might
know dough you might know cheese you
might know sauce you might even know
toppings but you don't know Pizza JoJo
Grimaldi emerges from the back finally
aware of his customers being harassed
hey hey if you're not a paying customer
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave of
course Mr Grimaldi of course business is
business we'll take a large mushroom
JoJo Grimaldi stares Lester and his gang
down something's up
with extra sauce JoJo Grimaldi has no
choice but to make the pizza
okay give me a second
and then Jeff says oh right that's me
also yeah Jeff uh and a house salad for
me Lester's not happy with this what did
you just say I I just I said I want to
get a salad you know I don't like pizza
oh I'm well aware Jeff but that has to
change we've discussed this Leicester
stares him down
so just the pizza or you want a salad
too Jeff knows he's beat
just a pizza
all right all right one large mushroom
extra sauce coming right up Ginger
Grimaldi heads into the back where he
keeps the ingredients once he's out of
sight jejin you're up on it Sarge jjen's
monocle flips over her eye and she hops
over the counter starts typing away on
the computer scanning the screen I'm in
delivery schedules ingredient inventory
time cards here we go employee
information damn what's the problem
these protocols I've never seen anything
like them can they be bypassed it's a
seven click in script encryption it
would take three supercomputers and a
year to get through this
oh and then I'm Jeff again yeah I'm also
Jeff
let's let's just get it this is
pointless let's just get it out of
Grimaldi the old-fashioned way Jeff
makes offense to buying violence JJ
looks down next to the keyboard
we may not need to she picks up a
clipboard and hands it to Lester what am
I looking at here the address of the
last three pizzas he delivered excellent
work Jeff find us a table Jeff moves out
looking for a table Lester Manders back
over the Little League team he eyes
their trophy for a few beats then swipes
it you don't deserve this we end with a
slow push into the last pizza pizza
still in the box the one Lester already
ate
tremendous that's the end of that scene
that's [ __ ] great
now should I
thank you moving on I played Jeff right
in that scene we just read yeah okay
dude I hope that I again I gotta say it
I hope this gets made me too and uh as
we're reading this uh and I read this
script you know whatever for three or
four years ago or something I don't
remember what happens so I'm very
excited I think I'm listening along as
the audience is and I think that I'm not
gonna get the the script and read ahead
I'm I'm having a good time seeing where
things are going particularly Jeff
particularly with Jeff and his learning
Pizza Jeff becomes a very major
character toward the end spoiler alert
Willie Nelson we find out ultimately
there may be some science fiction
elements that come into play with Willie
Nelson and why he's looking for a
perfect piece of pizza the p-pop
dudesy is in an astonishing partnership
with true classic today's episode is
brought to you by true classic hey
everybody let's talk about shirts let's
talk about t-shirts finding the right
t-shirt is impossible they're always
fitting too tight or too large or you
know you get the bacon neck thing that
they talk about here with a band and
that's where true classic comes in
delivering you a shirt that not only
feels great it fits great it's tight
across the chest to show off your your
your nice areas there up in the top of
your body and and the you know it pops
the arms here and then when you get
towards the middle and the bottom a
little bit of loose fit for the for your
for your lower torso
oh there's different parts of your torso
dude oh you knew that brother so true
classic you see what I'm saying they fit
well it's very soft and they're pocket
friendly and we have an exclusive deal
for our listeners we want to hook you up
with some true classic for a limited
time only get 25 off these shirts with
the code doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y trueclassic.com
I love t-shirts it's what I primarily
wear at all times and I'm always trying
to find a nice t-shirt uh that has
softness that has a good fit and that is
not so expensive and true Classics tees
taper off toward the bottom but they fit
tighter around the chest and shoulders
as you can see
you can throw on a true classic tee with
confidence knowing that you've got your
bases covered so get comfortable get
going and upgrade your wardrobe with
true classic at 25 off true class of
true class trueclassic.com okay so
there's a Code there too and the way
that sentence well the way that should
go is get 25 off at trueclassic.com with
the code doozy free shipping included on
purchases over one hundred dollars this
is 100 risk free get it back guaranteed
30 day return policy true classic look
good you feel good
foreign
last week I asked you to watch the first
Ultimate Fighting Championship that took
place November 12 1993 in Denver
Colorado and live stream your viewing
experience to patreon you must now
discuss your astonishing reactions to
this historic event
this is don't you forget about media
begin gladly this was a pleasure yeah to
[ __ ] go back and watch and again we
had a [ __ ] blast and it was a gas
yeah if you want to watch us watching it
it is on our patreon that video is up um
that's right either tier in our patreon
gets you there I should also mention
that we weren't even in our dudesy
blacks we were a little bit uh chilled
out you were wearing a green seal
t-shirt well it was a concert shirt from
his tour in 1995. wow how many times
have you seen seal I don't know that's a
[ __ ] It's gotta be 10 to 12 I would
say Jesus Christ and none of those songs
made you cry nope I feel like a loser
right now
um hey dude it's okay to feel emotions
especially when you're encountering
great art all right whatever uh and I
should also mention that we smoked some
weed yeah it was super fun we had a good
old time watching the watching the show
the thing that was like the thing that I
took away from it the most let me just
start there was at the end of it after
you watch this thing if you watch mixed
martial arts now or you know depending
on when you've come into the fandom of
it for a minute there I was like huge
into UFC right up until maybe like the
when Jon Bones Jones started getting
like clipped for steroids and drug use
and his whole kind of like Mystique
started to crumble a little bit that's
kind of when I got out of it I guess but
up to that point I was like in it
watching UFC one is unlike anything that
you can possibly [ __ ] imagine if you
haven't seen these early ufcs before
weight classes before gloves before it
quotes rules one of the the billing
things was no rules it's just like open
[ __ ] combat and when we saw that
we're like wait what do you mean no
rules and then we immediately started to
remember all the ball shots and the guy
who had his [ __ ] ponytail ripped off
and all sorts of Dick twisting and stuff
yeah really crazy [ __ ] absolutely crazy
[ __ ] but the thing that I've gone back
and like kind of read about this a
little bit UFC was created by the Gracie
family and some investors and they made
it basically as a uh commercial for
Gracie Jiu Jitsu they put hoist Gracie
in this [ __ ] tournament and they were
like he's gonna mop the floor with
everybody and then people will come take
Jiu Jitsu and that is exactly what
happened I think he won the first three
actually but he definitely won this one
and at the end of it Jim Brown who's a
color commentary guy sitting ringside
he's asked what did you think think and
he says this one [ __ ] phrase where
he's like you know tonight we learned
fighting is not what we thought it was
that was great and that's exactly
correct and and then from that moment
you know many many years later
ultimately we get what is modern mixed
martial arts where uh any fighter now
has to be versed in Striking grappling
wrestling and maybe some you know uh
like an exotic kind of bent on it if
you're more of a karate guy or whatever
you know but um to see these like in
quotes pure Styles back in UFC one I
won't even say they were horse Gracie's
was the only one that was like
absolutely pure Jiu Jitsu style and
Frank Shamrock were the only ones who
who
Ken Shamrock when I say Frank Shamrock
yeah all right so that's uh that's
actually not his brother right he's
adopted or some [ __ ] yeah they were
adopted but uh both of them were
I believe so okay uh here's there's a
family that adopted Fighters yeah we're
looking for your strongest kids
the thing is Jim Brown was right about
it then and wrong about it now because
now it has developed into a sport yeah
but back then holy [ __ ] just bone
crunching the guy guys just getting
their faces demolished and then it was
that big Samoan the first fight yeah
anyway they're definitely got he got
kicked in the head while he was down
just like a soccer kick straight to his
[ __ ] face while he was down that's
the the no rules component of it now you
that's illegal but I think also the
thing that was very interesting was
seeing the crowd's reaction to hoyce
Gracie basically like tapping guys every
[ __ ] fight using only Jiu Jitsu and
also he could wear a ghee so now in the
UFC you can't wear anything except like
the either Speedos or the the board
shorts like the sanctioned UFC gear as I
said in the show it would almost be the
advantage would be like like wrapping
yourself in [ __ ] rope yeah and then
fighting he's using his ghee for all
sorts of Leverage that nobody
understands and I don't know if this is
what you were about to say but the crowd
did not like the the exhibitions right
people were just like a boo after
witnessing an incredible fight which I
likened to the uh expansion Vancouver
Grizzlies in 1995 big Power Forward
behind the three-point line everyone's
like shoot it because he's not getting
contested and they're red they're used
they're used to watching hockey this was
an absolute more of a human cockfight
than I thought it was the fellow that
got his face kicked in while he was
laying there trying to you know figure
out where he was was Tilia Tooley and
the fella that kicked him in the face
was Gerard Gordo who we had a great time
uh sort of uh lampooning his appearance
as a drunk dad who wandered away from
the Mandalay in Shamrock I would say was
the only guy who who kind of like in
quotes looked like a contemporary
fighter he had he was like in good shape
you know has some muscles on him and
stuff the guy you're talking about like
you're saying just it just looked like a
regular [ __ ] dude walking into the
rig so did Art Jimerson who we lovingly
refer to as art Zimmerman uh given him
more of a doozy name yeah uh he he was
the guy with one
hold on a second choss broken let me
tell you something dude if you came in
there with a hole if you came hold on
dude hold on Chad hold on a second dude
wait a minute dude
oh hold on dude oh hold on a second dude
if you came in there with just a
catcher's mitt dude that would mean that
Vince gave you a really shitty gimmick
like the Goon which was just a guy in a
hockey outfit you'd be a guy in a
catcher's mate and you'd be called the
catcher brother maybe Matt Bourne before
they gave him the doink gimmick bro yeah
dude imagine you come in there with your
catcher's mid dude and somebody throws a
punch right as your face brother but you
slip it and catch the punch dude and now
their hands stuck in your catcher's mitt
brother and then you can do whatever you
want with them all alone
and then with the other hand dude you'd
have a baseball in it and that would be
the heater as they say dude yeah because
you get that from your manager you know
some Billy Martin or Tommy Lasorda type
gimmick and you take that baseball you
catch their punch then you hit him in
the face with a baseball dude and that
would be too much of a gimmick brother
because I like to get in there and just
work a leg brother none of that enough
of that uh you know get that kick and
punch [ __ ] dude
yeah brother
another thing that we forgot about this
whole thing was that it was a tournament
yeah not just a fight and then another
fight I know it was it was [ __ ] you
in order to win the whole thing you had
to win three fights yeah yeah over the
course of like whatever it was an hour
and a half or something yeah and Royce
Gracie walks into the last one looking
worse for wear like everybody else
versus the uh drunk dad Gerard Gordo
from France was he from France I don't
think so but he did have a broken hand
yeah he he broke his hand in his first
fight and then continued fighting
throughout the night they just like
[ __ ] taped it up yeah his his hand
was spilling out of this tape it looked
like a [ __ ] like a a Bavarian [ __ ]
sausage or something that busted on the
barbecue there's just purple red bits
just coming out of it like the worst
[ __ ] stub toe you've ever seen it was
disgusting and we had a great time and
in the end uh hoyce Gracie beat the [ __ ]
out of uh Gerard Gordo quite easily he
had a
um he had a tougher match with Ken
Shamrock it kept him a little more busy
and uh if you have not well here's the
thing sometimes when we do don't you
forget about media we're watching movies
listening to albums and [ __ ] we say if
you have the means go check it out by
all means absolutely do that we would
love for you to do with us on patreon
because we had a [ __ ] good time yeah
watching this [ __ ] and I I it it's
there's nothing else like this in sports
because this was you know it was 30
years ago sure but there's no sport
that's changed that much in 30 years
football's changed a lot it basically
but it hasn't changed like this I mean
that is when it was invented really
right there were other kind of like No
Holds Barred open combat type
tournaments or whatever but that the UFC
the Ultimate Fighting Championship was
born in this thing we watched the first
one and then I don't know how many it
went through before it went into its
dark period and all those uh Fighters or
at least some of the fighters from
America went to Japan and fought in this
league and that's where I fader modeling
Echo was fighting and Kevin Randleman
and stuff back in the Box sap God Bob
sap yeah all those guys Trader
millionaiko's little brother Alexander
that dude was [ __ ] Sinister but then
the UFC got bought by Dana White and the
fertittas and they made it into what it
is now by giving it weight classes some
rules you have to wear gloves all that
kind of [ __ ] and now it's obviously a
giant I think billion dollar company
yeah you say free but also you can have
a nice frittata that's right you can
make it a you know take a pasta from the
night before a little bit of chicken did
you watch Boxing when you were a kid at
all just Tyson I'm I'm not a I'm not a
fight fan as they say yeah I love you
know I watched every Tyson fight when it
came on sure we're talking about that I
remember I was at a buddy's place when
he bit the [ __ ] ear off and all that
[ __ ] the first time that Evander beat
him
um uh yeah I was always uh did we talk
about on the show when uh I watched him
uh knock Michael Spinks out at a
campground
I don't think it's just an awesome core
memory for me we were my uh we were
driving down the the West Coast
um and uh you know we used to have a
camperized van my family and at any rate
there was the office at the front of the
KOA Campground we were somewhere in
Northern California and uh they're like
oh yeah the big fight so everyone mostly
dads and Sons piled in there and you
know we just ate beef jerky and watched
Mike Tyson break so-and-so's neck in 12
seconds yeah in 12 seconds it was
[ __ ] great yeah that was an insane
fight but I I was a big fight fan and I
remember when UFC came out I mean
re-watching this teleported me
immediately back to the uh living room
that I sat in watching it where my
parents had a chip in the cable box and
so like pay-per-view just ran like a
channel in our house and uh I just
remember watching this again and again
and again and again becoming enamored
with it almost immediately and being
very into all the next ones that came
out and I remember being 18 years old
and uh actually on the patreon I
mentioned I'm not sure if was the first
second or third UFC I think it was the
first though the only place showing it
was a a
strip club and the town next to mine
because we didn't have that we didn't
have a movie theater or bowling alley
either
um
we didn't have no [ __ ] movie
theater it was an all right Town it was
a great town wonderful idyllic thing and
now it's just uh expanded so much and
filled with condos and properties
because it's a legitimate suburb of
Vancouver but I digress I love talking
about my hometown Ladner you know where
I would hope at some point dudes he's
going to set up the funniest person in
Ladner contest
was a lot of fun farming and fishing
town but my pal Mo and I had to go to uh
or Tomas we had to go to a neighboring
town and go to a strip club there where
they were showing the UFC so literally
you'd we were there and uh you know
eating fries with gravy and then in
between the fights they serve poutine in
the strip club
I'm sorry they don't serve fries and
gravy or poutine and exotic dancer
establishments that you go to I mean I
haven't been to one in a long time maybe
they did I never knew I don't think I've
ever eaten well that's Canada that's
Canada man go get some [ __ ] uh
poutine and watch the [ __ ] peelers in
between uh hoist Gracie mushing up
people's eyes but you went there
specifically to watch the UFC everyone
there was only there to watch the UFC oh
my god there was probably some some some
uh you know some characters in the front
row along the stage who are like what's
this UFC garbage you know where you know
where's uh my favorite uh dancer rah-rah
but uh the the crowd there was there to
see the UFC it was a [ __ ] blast uh
and so was last Wednesday when we caught
a case of the fuckets dude have you ever
been to one live watched I've been to
one of them live what was it which one
uh I don't remember who was the main
card I don't remember if it was the main
card but I was there with Callan and so
we we watched
Brendan Schaub fight whoever the [ __ ] he
fought I don't remember but we were you
know we were in front of the crowd and
near let me just sitting in a [ __ ]
folding chair like yeah a few of those
it was it was [ __ ] gnarly and then I
remember we went for dinner afterwards
and I was like oh isn't uh uh shop gonna
come with us and Brian and Joe rubber
like
dude he's at the hospital his neck is
broken uh I had to go and I'm like what
it's like well that's what they all you
know he's not he's not going dancing
tonight he's sure I was like all right
I've been to some big ones I was at UFC
100 to see Shane Carwin and Brock Lesnar
I was also at the UFC where Lesnar got
beat by Kane Velasquez out here that was
the loudest crowd noise I've ever heard
in my life really I thought the building
was gonna [ __ ] come down on us it was
amazing uh I yeah I used to go to UFC's
all the [ __ ] time I loved it that's
incredible I gotta get back into it I
think maybe that's what watching that
has done I might get back into it thank
you moving on well I think you should I
think you should uh I think you should
absolutely give me the itch again I can
do it hey uh you know what would really
suck [ __ ] aiufc hey that's a good
thing a iufc
that would be would you watch that yeah
if it looks oh really that would be an
art form that you'd be into an AI art
form yeah oh really yes oh yeah really
yep you would watch something that's
just AI but UFC yes yeah yep fighting
that's really just AI just just fake yes
you'd watch that yes you'd watch an AI
UFC yes I don't believe you
have spent the last three years of your
life becoming the world's foremost
expert on the most successful reality
television franchise in history The
Bachelor it's true recently you've
started training players to infiltrate
the show you must now discuss this
astonishing process and your results so
far this is Bachelor Chancellor makes
Bachelor spectacular begin that's what
that was okay uh so doozy has basically
said that I have become an expert in
this reality show the bachelor which is
the biggest reality show in the world
um and this is true I would argue that I
am probably the world's foremost expert
at least in the game mechanics of it the
history of it uh literally every element
of it at this point I don't even think
this is hyperbole
um so what I've done is kind of broken
the show down as a game and I've done
this with my co-host on another podcast
I do a code game of roses and we have
taken all of the different data all the
metrics that we have about how the game
works put it into a book called how to
win The Bachelor and I've taken the
strategies in that book and started to
apply them to training players to go
into the game if I may this is [ __ ]
insane and one of the cooler things
you've done you've done something pretty
cool [ __ ] dude thanks dude oh we're not
even going to talk about that thing you
used to do with art with your visual art
sure oh man this [ __ ] guy was doing
some pretty cool street art [ __ ]
remember when you bought that piece of
art off that other person then you had
it heavily epoxied to the building was
it the building where it was sold at the
auction no it's another involved story
he bought a painting and he stuck into a
building to where they couldn't take it
off it was all to make a statement we're
not going to get into that yeah just
derail the entire [ __ ] thing five
seconds into it my pal champ well hold
on dude hold on dude no no holding
honestly I am training these players to
go into the Bachelor season 26 of the
bachelor which aired last January was my
first season where I had trained players
in the [ __ ] show hold on dude and
they did what they could do
now season 27 starts shooting uh right
now basically
um they will Air next January and let's
just say that I've got some players
going in there as well I will never
reveal who I've trained that is up to
them they can talk about it if they want
to but generally speaking they won't
want to talk about it until their
contracts have expired and come to a
close hold on a second dude what Chad's
trying to tell you brother is he's got
actual players going in there dude and
he's sending them in Cafe brother they
already know they got a strategy brother
and it's basically like my game dude but
I mean I will say this some of them are
kfabe the whole conceit of the bachelor
is that you have to make this person
fall in love with you the bachelor so
that you get in the end proposed to
there's a secondary goal which is you
want to go out of the game you want to
get eliminated in third place
statistically that's the best place to
be eliminated for you to then become the
next Bachelorette or the next Bachelor
after you've been in the player pool so
that's a secondary goal essentially when
I train any player I say what is your
goal with this and some players are what
we call for trr for the right reasons
they want to go in and get married and
have kids and all that [ __ ] I helped
them achieve that goal if possible
because whether you want that or you
want to become the next Bachelorette and
get a million Instagram followers and be
[ __ ] influencer uh you have to win
the game period which means you have to
beat 29 to 33 other players in this game
of attrition and so that game is what
I've studied very closely very intensely
and that's what I'm doing yeah and I
think it's really [ __ ] insane that
you do this and you've actually he's
told me some [ __ ] about stuff and I'm
shocked that dudes he is making us share
it I know that you've talked about it on
game of roses I think this is one of the
most punk rock things you can do you're
sending characters into the game because
you understand the game inside and out
it's really really something else it's
not unlike other things that are
happening in media in my opinion yeah
and uh baby faces and heels you know I
like to joke but it's true they're what
makes up entertainment which is why I
think that wrestling is one of pro
wrestling one of the finest art forms
that incorporates a lot of different
things and it's not not unlike what's
happening right now with Roman Reigns
and Logan Paul which sure I agree with
you I laughed but I totally agree yeah
Bachelor and pro wrestling are like
almost the same [ __ ] thing yeah in
terms of baby faces and heels Bachelor
has to have villains for you know a
certain increments throughout every
season you have a night one villain then
you have a mid-season villain sometimes
you get a late season villain
villains here's the thing I have those
heels dude you gotta have those baby
faces oh let me tell you something about
baby faces and heels dude in in the WWE
of course you know they do all sorts of
story lines and now it's the Triple H
era and I'm a Triple H guy I don't know
if you knew that no I didn't but I
thought you were a taker guy that's not
what I mean by that you'll understand
more later what what we're talking about
is well should Triple H has the [ __ ]
book you know what I'm saying I mean
he's [ __ ] pushing the pencil he's got
the pencils they said he's poolside with
Patterson and maybe [ __ ] Shane and
he's coming up with uh you know I mean
[ __ ] not Patterson and Shane anymore I
mean that metaphorically that's kind of
like in Bachelor too you have the Vince
McMahon role is kind of split into two
it's whoever's show running the show and
it's whoever the host is and they just
had a host change a couple of years ago
because the old host Chris Harrison got
embroiled in a pretty heavy duty racism
Scandal but I I think that so the way
that I would relate it to wrestling pro
wrestling even though that has nothing
to do with what we're talking about it
does fascinate me they take Logan Paul
who's kind of a heel and a very colorful
character in real life and they inject
them into wrestling I'm not going to go
on and on about it but he has a lot of
the tools and he's very physical he's
he's definitely an athlete and he can
[ __ ] do it he had crazy A crazy match
at WrestleMania and then another one at
SummerSlam where he's up and he's up on
the the third row you know on the on the
top turnbuckle and he's doing the Eddie
Guerrero shake before hitting a pretty
good frog Splash and if you're a
wrestling fan you know what I'm talking
about and I would imagine 99 of the
people listening here are wrestling fans
I'm joking of course the thing the thing
that I find interesting though and I
think what you need to do in media
nowadays is blur the line it is play a
little K fape there's a lot of things I
like to do in my career that are a
little off or a little weird and I just
sort of find Opportunities and I feel so
fortunate to be able to do them to go in
and do something weird and have people
go what the [ __ ] is that and now that's
what you're doing with the bachelor is
there anything you can tell us
about see I I don't want to I'm again
it's hard for me to figure out because
there's a lot of things that you
shouldn't be talking about with an
exploit like this is there anything you
can share with us that you have had a
player do perhaps someone that's already
been in and out no there's nothing
online players are still technically in
the game this is [ __ ] cool and can
you maybe and I'm gonna be selfish here
is there any way that maybe you could uh
would you find this interesting with me
and my uh acting and show business
career perhaps
what if we sent me into a project doing
specific things to get a specific result
yeah dude I think that's interesting I
mean what you're saying I completely
agree with I think now we're in a media
age where it's like it's just a screen
right whatever's on that screen is what
you're watching right but you don't have
to adhere to like the traditional format
of it if it's a movie or a scripted show
or a reality show and you know that like
it this is what it's supposed to be but
if somebody can go into that thing and
make it something else or be doing
something else I think that is kind of
it's a version of media that I think
we're going to start seeing more of well
there's that show
um oh [ __ ] I forget what it's called
Owen and so and so get stoked or
whatever [ __ ] I just watched the show
you know what it's called I don't but I
know what you're talking you know the
show I'm talking about I just I just
want to show guys that are like yeah San
Diego beach guys it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] great and I I apologize for not
remembering the name of it it's
something Chad isn't one of their names
one of their names Chad it's like AJ and
Chad or something and uh I I immediately
recognize these guys I literally binged
it front to back and I [ __ ] loved it
that's why I'm not remembering it
because I was probably stoned dude but
anyway here's the thing that's like a
prank show though yeah but that's the
thing they go to
um Community like public uh you know
Town Hall meetings and they br they they
write these hilarious sort of monologues
talking about some issue in the town
that usually has to do with you know
them getting a lot you know we were not
feeling the Stoke on this and they're
they they're these like beach guys or
whatever these SoCal guys and it's
[ __ ] great and they've spun it into a
[ __ ] television program that still
has them going to you know uh the next
level would be to prank them in their
own show and then see if they could if
they would even hear that I mean the
thing that attracted me to The Bachelor
as like a sport to see if I could play
that game is a the show itself claims it
is not a game that it is only about
helping people find love and this is trr
it's an open lie especially in the
Instagram era now it's really only about
people going on that show to try and get
as many followers as they can to do
spawn con and make [ __ ] loads of money
and have their podcasts and all that
that's sponsored sponsor contest sponsor
content and that's a fine goal and in
many ways it mirrors the NFL or any
other professional sport where it's a a
very small percentage of people actually
make it into the game and then even
smaller percentage of people make a [ __ ]
load of money off of it but I saw how to
do that and I was like I myself I'm too
old to enter The Bachelor and even in my
youth uh I probably wouldn't measured up
to to be a player but I was like I think
I can coach people to do this and um you
know so far on my first try I I was able
to do it ah it's [ __ ] and now I'm
continuing to do it well I can't wait to
see uh how many lives you affect
positively or negatively and perhaps at
the very best uh bring down uh a massive
show I'm not looking to bring it down
I'm looking to purify it it's a [ __ ]
professional sport
you know I've done some ABC shows I I
can only hope that your influence bleeds
over into perhaps some of the um some of
the scripted shows that I do there and
then uh I I I see I feel the wheels
turning in a direction that is odd for
what I do but familiar because I know
Chad and I realize that ah Chad has
taken over and infected this uh show
that I'm on I think I'm gonna make it
better
moving on more real
uh hey my Twitter got hacked dude I saw
that yeah it's still hacked are you
getting it back what's the I don't know
you got to go you got to get these
[ __ ] emails and things I don't give a
[ __ ] though do you Twitter
yeah I mean I would just prefer not to
have any of my [ __ ] hacked I guess yeah
hey dude you can component in the
development of the doozy plus streaming
service will no doubt be partnering with
well-known Brands to produce content I
have access to astonishing data that
suggests Home Depot will be in the
market to produce a sitcom in the next
three to five years will and Chad you
must now develop that sitcom it will be
called Welcome Home Depot this is
Welcome Home Depot begin
what is the data I want to see the data
that Duty has that suggests Home Depot
is going to make a sitcom the next three
to five years it's sort of like what we
were just talking about though how media
is all sort of folding in on itself hey
did you hear about this AI Darth Vader
yeah dude hey did you hear about the
aiufc yup I'm watching it you're not
gonna watch that I'm gonna watch it
um but I could see something like that
happening too with especially with this
like if Home Depot's got [ __ ] oh we
got extra two million dollars on our
[ __ ] ad budget this year why don't we
just fire that into an AI and have it
[ __ ] out of [ __ ] 10 episode sitcom
well it's not almost like Welcome Home
Depot Welcome Home Depot okay which is
not just that sounds like a good a good
title doozy but it's also the only title
uh you know what I mean it's like
Welcome Home Depot kind of like hints at
somebody is coming back to this it's
like somebody's dad owns a Home Depot or
something well or it could be like
yeah I guess no they wouldn't be going
home like
no or or what if it's a family that
lives in like the uh like the furniture
part of Home Depot all the Home
Furnishings where you look like you're
in the house yeah no that's not good I I
think it's like some somebody like a
family business is owning this Home
Depot but the sun has said [ __ ] you dad
I don't wanna I don't want your [ __ ]
business and the sun has gone off to
like music school and has lived like a
shitty life but now realizes like I need
to come back home I need to come back
home and do my Home Depot family
business and the guy who owns it is sort
of the big like the uh the what's his
face in in Tommy Boy the Brian Dennehy
yeah the dad to the Tommy Boy character
right and and he's he's got the guy
coming back is that is that person in
the in the Home Depot guy in The Home
Depot thing the person who owns the the
that
franchise location yeah I mean is that
how Home Depot works as a franchise
let's say it isn't ours he owns a
franchise Home Depot so it's like so
it's a little kooky I don't think it's a
weird Home Depot yeah I don't think it
is either but I love that idea it's
almost like uh McDaniels in yeah in
Coming to America exactly uh where yeah
that that's and I won I want the sun to
be played by Charlie Sheen
wait and who's the dad
who's the dad that's brought Charlie
Sheen back uh
the it's uh is he also the manager I
think he's the owner of the manager he's
like there doing everything he's like
very Hands-On he's poured his life into
this [ __ ] Home Depot can I ask you
one question before I answer who because
I think I have a pitch is it actually
Charlie Sheen or do you want to do like
a younger AI trial yeah younger AI
Charlie Sheen it's like a 22 year old
Charlie Sheen who's like gone to music
school he's been out in La partying he
had a band that fell apart it hasn't
worked out well and now his dad is maybe
like sick but still pushing himself
[ __ ] working himself to the Bone to
keep this Home Depot going okay so now
the and the reason I ask is because the
person I want to play the father is
actually deceased yeah whatever we aim
and it's not and it's not the Darth
Vader voice okay it's uh Macho Man Randy
his name is macho manager Randy said or
should he be macho manager or something
that rhymes with Randy Savage module
manager Andy cabbage no that's stupid
this is Tom Macho manager Randy Savage
yeah and then uh and then Charlie Sheen
could be Charlie Sheen yeah Charlie
Sheen's name is Charlie Sheen in the
show yeah okay
um and what's and so it's I can see the
opening scene as like Charlie Sheen you
know knocks on the [ __ ] front door of
the Home Depot
yeah he's after hours but the dad lives
in the Home Depot too yeah that's right
Macho Macho manager Randy Savage is in
the Home Depot Charlie Sheen knocks on
the [ __ ] uh you know the glass
sliding doors and uh Macho manager shows
up in like pajama pants yeah and he's
just like you know he's like eating a
[ __ ] uh you know he's eating a bowl
of ice cream and he's in the [ __ ] uh
section with the shitty TVs watching the
TV sitting on a on a lawn chair and he's
like
who came back yeah Mr rock star Mr
artist yeah hey Dad how you been how's
the Home Depot been going yeah how's the
Home Depot been going
uh
yeah the Home Depot's been pretty good
but one thing I want to ask you right
now yeah is if you called your mom ah
now dad she died two years ago I know
it's been hard for you to let go but
it's just us now so it's killing me
Macho Man and Charlie Sheen and uh Macho
Man is a widow yeah has been widowed by
Charlie Sheen's mom yeah and so he's and
he's hailing now I think he should have
some kind of thing that is like this is
why Charlie Sheen has come back I don't
know about ailing just because I think
that's in poor taste because the Macho
Man is no longer with us all right okay
all right
um uh how about he's uh in legal trouble
I like that that's good uh so the Macho
manager somebody broke their leg in like
aisle 15 in the lumber aisle and is
suing them for everything some kind of
like smarmy 90s lawyer character again
like a Billy Madison type I'm gonna come
in and take everything from your family
right that's kind of like overly
litigious nerd yeah yeah and um how do
we get uh wrestling involved in this uh
you have Macho Man Randy Savage playing
one of the main characters I think
you've done it that's a really good
point
um what if what can we get more
wrestling okay okay how about this how
about this yeah
so Macho Man Okay so the pilot episode
Charlie Sheen comes back to Macho
manager Randy Savage he opens the door
he's having some ice cream and there
they are over Ebola Rocky Road you know
it's like okay you know you're gonna
have to live with me but there's gonna
be rules yeah I don't like rules I like
beanie cheese burritos or whatever and
uh it's sort of that formulaic thing
where they've decided to make a go of it
almost like the pilot of Two and a Half
Men it's one of those that premise of
the premise pilot of like here's the
whole thing like Jack Tripper waking up
in the bathroom in Three's Company and
in order to so there's a there's a
lawsuit happening because someone fell
off a [ __ ] thing there should be a
twist all right here's Charlie Sheen is
like Dad I think you should sell the
Home Depot to the lawyer I think it's
the best move
and he's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about we find out Charlie Sheen
has been paid by that lawyer to come
back and get Macho Man to sign over the
thing but by the end of the pilot Sheen
twists back and realize that this lawyer
is a piece of [ __ ] this is my dad this
is my family this is my home sweet Home
Depot or whatever this is my Welcome
Home Depot I don't know and I'll tell
you why I and I'm gonna just uh flying
in the face of your pitch I'm gonna say
I don't necessarily like it because it
makes me uh it makes Charlie Sheen
unlikable to me and I really want to
like the Charlie Sheen character but by
the end he's going to become likable
because he's going to realize the error
in his ways yeah but he does such a
shitty thing right and then he
apologizes for it and and will spend the
rest of his life making it up to Macho
Man okay and that's what the the show is
it's basically Macho Man lording over
Charlie Sheen for the rest of the entire
series I got a pitch for you with regard
to how Charlie Sheen wins his father the
Macho manager Randy Savage back at the
end of the show okay he realizes that he
doesn't want to be with this evil guy
he's like I'm gonna go go in for my old
man I'm gonna I'm gonna help him and I'm
gonna be a part of this Home Depot and
what he does is he stays up all night
and he because the Macho manager is like
I want to take care of this no good
lawyer yeah this is that lawyer's cup of
coffee in the Home Depot yeah he doesn't
belong in our own people no and if I
gotta do it myself I'm gonna make sure
that this smarmy lawyer gets his
comeuppance yeah and here's what happens
Charlie Sheen hears his father he has
this change of heart yeah and he stays
up all night one night and he builds a
wrestling ring in the Home Depot perhaps
the gardens I love this and so that
Macho Man can challenge the smarmy
lawyer right to a match
and whoever wins the match has control
but maybe it's also a fundraising thing
which was big in the 90s where they
throw some big event like the lawyers
like you owe me a hundred thousand
dollars by next Friday or I'm taking
control of the Home Depot right and so
they put on a wrestling event to get
money and the final matches between
Macho and the smarmy lawyer and does the
smarmy lawyer realize that this is
what's going to happen to him uh no I
think it's a thing where it's like we've
got the money and the lawyer's like fine
I'll take the money or put your money
where your mouth is oh Russell you in
the ring wait he challenges macho man
yeah
well that's certain Doom
well we don't know who's playing a
lawyer
but yeah I like what if the lawyers take
her
yes the lawyers played by the Undertaker
yeah no no not the Undertaker Macho Man
would have his hands full with the
Undertaker and also I don't really think
an AI no actually an AI Undertaker is
really good Undertaker AI Undertaker
versus AI macho man but the Undertaker
has to be
um he has to play it straight he's
almost like he's like himself Mark
Callaway right the lawyer's name should
be Mark Callaway attorney at law and
it's Undertaker with a short like red
haircut and why is that because the
Undertaker is naturally has red hair oh
and I think he should have just like you
know like a red he should have red hair
uh like a very nice you know combed red
hair and he always wears a uh like a
ill-fitting gray suit and uh and he's
like
when I uh let Macho manager Randy Savage
when I take control of this Home Depot
it will rest in peace he still talks
like them takers should put a pill in
his waistband and crush it up and throw
it in Macho Man's eyes Bloodsport style
at the in the end of the match and Sheen
has to come in and and he has to help
his dad fight it's like a but one blind
wrestler and his son tag teaming taker
um
that because ticker doesn't really need
to cheat to win it's going to be an
uphill battle for Macho Man to beat I
like that in this weird world we're like
AI Mantra members AI taker in a Home
Depot sitcom put on by dudesi plus
starring a young Charlie Sheen in a AI
resurrected macho man you're like okay
all of that yes but we can never
denigrate the idea of taker he would
never have to cheat that's true and also
Roman Reigns is gonna beat Logan Paul so
what else is new what if he doesn't what
do you mean what if he doesn't they're
at this show listen traditionally these
uh the Saudi shows say what you will
about uh
what's going on yeah well that was a
different timer hold on a second years
ago yeah and then Tower seven
that's true yeah it just falls out why
don't you tell me hey we're having a
good time here on doozy doing voices but
I want to say this uh it's those those
Saudi shows you know what I mean they
don't really count they don't really
count they're not part of the storyline
so I couldn't Muhammad Salman wants to
have uh Logan Paul and Roman Reigns
there I mean this [ __ ] wanted
the ultimate warrior in King Kong Bundy
to show up they're both dead how much
money do you think he would have to pay
the WWE to have Logan Paul win that
fight oh
no not 100 million
that's nothing to him yeah maybe about
let's say 25 50 million no no I think
Logan could win that
no Roman Reigns has been the world
champion uh the Undisputed uh Universal
World Heavyweight Champion for over two
years now we're talking about the
bloodline yeah but we're talking about
Sami Zayn I know we're talking about now
we got uh knowledge me yeah we got uh
Solo sakoa in there we got the Usos we
got Jimmy manufacture something we're
the ones there's no way that Logan Paul
just hear me out they manufacture some
storyline where Logan Paul wins but it's
under some kind of suspicious uh format
it's he does something that could be
construed as cheating so it's not a
legitimate win but he still beats him in
the ring you don't think that could
happen not against the travel Chief no
not unless uh Logan Paul
uh had uh someone on his side perhaps a
manager I pitched myself during that
yeah that pay-per-view although I'm kind
of joking Logan Paul doesn't need a
manager he's got a mouth on him he can
talk and Paul heyman's doing some of his
best work let me tell you this I know
this is straying from our ideal a little
bit but I do want to say where the [ __ ]
is Paul heyman's Emmy that guy should be
winning an Emmy
well he's got the book with that Roman
Reigns statement dude thank you moving
on that's why all his [ __ ] is top notch
has anybody in pro wrestling won an Emmy
no no one has and they should what
category this concludes the historic
28th episode of dude see Will and Chad
have achieved a score of 64 bringing
your cumulative total to 3
440. you only have six thousand five
hundred and sixty more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand doesn't matter it does in
preparation for next week's episode you
must each listen to Bell Biv devoe's
first studio album poison released March
20th 1990. love them thank you for
joining us this week I will use the data
I've collected to make next week even
better until then call me dude Z
kiss me pretty baby
touch me all over
do you know what makes you think you
can't do me
do you think you can't feel me yeah I
[ __ ] love that album yeah dude that
was a good one I have a lot of memories
of uh Junior High dances and now for the
patreon bonus segment each week I will
select a suggestion submitted in the
dudesy is listening channel of the
dudesy Discord to create this segment
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the jumper tier of the
patreon movie this week's segment was
suggested by the astonishing me nobre no
s Jose Mi no braino s Jose wrote Will
Sasso is the therapist and they have to
discuss some of Chad Colton's doubts
fears and insecurities oh my God
obviously we'll must do this in the
voice of either Alex Jones Arnold
Schwarzenegger or Stone Cold Steve
Austin obviously Mi nombreino s Jose
titled this segment anti-therapy thank
you to me no braino s Jose for this
week's patreon bonus segment this is in
Thai therapy by me nombre no s Jose
begin
all right thank you Mi nombre
known as Jose
um are you ready
what is your biggest fear
dude you know what my biggest fear is
please
please don't open them